Hey I'm Jad Abumrad, I am Robert
Kobish this is Radiolab and today
things, and I just, I wanted to check
in. This is the usual radio lab style,
which means that I can
basically natter on forever.
All right, so this is Alison Gopnik.
She's a professor of psychology and
philosophy at the University of California
at Berkeley and the author
of the philosophical baby.
And the reason we called
her up is that, you know,
truthfully after the egg situation,
we broken egg to make this program.
And if you're just joining us, we
weren't planning to, it just happened.
We feel really crappy
about it frankly. But, um,
you got us thinking about the fragility
of objects and for me that call to mind,
um, an idea that I've always been
thinking about, uh, you know,
being the father of two young
kids about object permanence,
which is this whole idea in a child's
psychology that when babies are really
young, when an object
disappears from their view,
they think it's gone forever. So
that's the peekaboo game. Exactly.
It's what makes it fun because like
from their perspective thought is you're
gone forever and then you're back and
you're gone forever and then you're back.
So, uh, I thought this would be a
cool idea for us to explore about how,
like from the very beginning,
we're born with no concept that
objects should stick around.
But when we talked with Alison Gopnik,
the first thing she told us was that, uh,
well, it's, it's a little
more complicated than that.
Of course, right? It's science.
And so we got into a conversation
that went in some strange directions,
but she began by telling
us about some new research,
which shows that actually babies do
have an idea that objects stick around.
You know,
if you do these experiments where you
show them an object behind a screen and
then you make disappear, they think,
Whoa, where did it go? It should be there.
Exactly. Whoa. You know,
the wo because babies look much longer
at things that they don't expect it or
surprising. It's as if they're sitting
there saying, you know, what's the, um,
they very rarely finish,
right? So I was wrong,
fine. But here's the
really surprising thing.
Now suppose what happens is a yellow duck
goes behind the screen moving left to
right and then out the other
side instead of the yellow duck,
there's a little blue
bunny. No, most adults,
if they saw this would be like what the,
but the babies are totally
blahzay about that.
What if a yellow duck goes in one side
of the screen and then magically the blue
doc appears on the other side of the
screen until they're about a year old.
Babies don't seem to be fazed by that.
And she suspects that the reason for that
is that the most important thing about
the duck to the babies is not that
it is yellow or round or duck.
Like in any way it was its trajectory,
its story, what it did in the past,
what its history is like.
This is an object that was moving left
to right and when it emerged from the
screen it was still an
object moving left to right.
And there are experiments with
adults that are kind of amazing,
where you sort of see the same thing.
You take a room full of divide
them in half. You say, okay,
everybody on the left, half of the
room is now going to get a, you know,
university kept California at Berkeley
Mug and then you say to them, all right,
all of you guys who have a Mug, how
much would you sell your monk for?
And then you ask the people on
the other side of the class,
how much would you pay to buy that Mug?
And you get people to write it
down on a piece of paper. Well,
it turns out the people who actually
already have the Mug on their desk think
that it's much more valuable than the
people on the other side. So they,
they would demand much more for their mug.
Keep in mind they've only
spent one minute with this Mug,
but somehow over that minute she says
the Mug gets imbued with something,
some kind of essence.
There's something, and again, you
can see this even with children,
there's something about mindness,
there's something about possession.
About the relationship that I have to
the objects that I care about that goes
beyond just what their
superficial features are.
Oh, I think that makes such
deeply obvious sense to me.
I'm surprised that it
was even in discovery.
If I have a relationship
with the thing like, ah,
I'm going to see my girlfriend and the
railroad man gives me the ticket and it
turns out to be a fabulous date.
Then I put the ticket in my pocket
and I saved the ticket for 40 years.
Anytime I want to go back to the
day that I had the great date,
I just touched the ticket.
Yeah. I don't have that at all. You
don't have that at all? Well, no.
I have it a little bit, but I
just know I s I throw it I, yeah,
you throw them away. Hey, throw them
away. You got a purge man. You know,
some of us are more sentimental about
the past and about objects than than
others are, and she says,
ah. Interestingly, that
for those Weirdos like you,
Robert who gets super
romantic about there's things,
there might be a deep
evolutionary reason for it.
Now you always have to take these
evolutionary reasons with a grain of salt.
But she says if you look
at patterns of passion,
for example, is what it's
called in biology. You know,
like the squirrel who hides is nuts. Um,
the squirrels keep really good track
of which nuts they have and what their
histories are.
And one possibility is that some of our
relationship about at least physical
objects stems from this history of the
history of being mammals who keep track
of what we've got and what we don't
have. It's my inner squirrel. Right?
You know, we do talk about
people squirreling things away.
Is there something that's got this kind
of deeper evolutionary background and I
think there is some evidence that,
but isn't there also like a
counter squirrel instinct?
I mean like there's that famous thing
with observation that young male baboons
when they get to a certain age will
get gripped by wanderlust and then just
wander away from the troop. And which
is good because it prevents inbreeding.
Yeah.
I think there is actually reason to
think that we all live on this kind of
emotional, bungee cord, you know, boiling
between the Squirrel and the baboon.
And she says it's interesting to think
about like what's gonna Happen to our bun
genus now that we're entering a
world where objects are becoming just
information.
What will happen when we have three d
printers that are going to be like the
replicators on Star Trek that can,
uh, just keep producing replicas of,
of objects might actually mess with
some of our most basic instincts.
Philosophers, philosophers are always
great about having wonderful, crazy, um,
thought experiments to
try to demonstrate this.
So one of them is the swamp man.
It's a famous thought experiment,
not exactly clear why it's a swamp
man and not some other kind of man.
But here's how it goes. Here's
the story of the swamp, man.
Magine you're standing next to a swamp,
you're you and in the swamp it's a bunch
of bubbling gases, chemical reactions,
bubbling and interacting
in some weird organic way.
But whatever you just
standing there, but then,
okay,
a bolt of lightning comes out of
the sky and kills you and that,
oh, the other one comes out
of the sky, hits the swamp,
catalyzing all that chemistry into
overdrive and somehow miraculously,
for just a moment, the reactions come
together and just the right way to form.
Hi, I'm Robert. Oh Man.
Completely identical to you,
Robert, Robert, and brand new you.
If you took every single
molecule in the swamp man's body,
it would be exactly like yours at this
very moment. So here's the question.
Does swamp Robert Remember that date or
does swamp Robert Care about the ticket?
You're saying that swamp gas rubber
is molecule for molecule Adam for Adam
molecule for molecule. This Robert
Right here. Exactly. So you're saying,
are the memories and experiences of his
life suddenly contained in that facts?
Emily, that's the question. And
most people's intuition is no, no,
absolutely not. Absolutely not. I'm
not even hesitated. Why? Why not?
Why didn't I believe that my date and
the ticket that took me to that date,
they belong to me and not to Adams and,
but I don't have you asked me what's
the difference between me and my Adams?
I don't know, but I know
it's there. Right? Well,
because the atoms have you sitting
right there actually went on that date.
Where's the atoms of swamp gas?
Robert weren't there. Right?
You think you got it? Exactly right.
Yet it's something about the history.
It's the fact that, you know, Robert's
Adam's really were in that place.
They really were there with that
person. And, um, although I could,
I could tell a version of the swamp
gas Robert that would, I think,
solve this problem if Robert, this
Robert instead of the lightning,
he just got into the
swamp, submerged himself,
commingled his Adams with the swamp
gas Adams, and then he got out,
went on his way. If then later,
even like years later, the swamp,
I'm Robert spat out of copy.
The fact that the real Robert was there
to begin with and that the copy somehow
touched on almost like a baton passing.
I could see that the date
would be in the copy.
I think you might be [inaudible] or
do you get with me? I think I'm right.
I've always it to myself
with you list a sense of touch that is,
my wife has a very different
view of this to me,
but I one day was sitting
around in the office,
get a letter unbidden from the first
man on the moon from Neil Armstrong.
Just write something about I written,
he sort of who you got to do it and it
says commander Neil Armstrong and it's
very flattering. And if it
had come in any other form,
but by email I would've framed it.
I would've given it a
special place of honor.
But since it arrived from a machine to
my machine and then out of a machine to
another machine to a flat piece of
paper, you can't give it to thank here.
Give it to the ticket to the deep
thing. Huh? Can't, that's weird.
Why? Because Neil Armstrong
never touched it. [inaudible]
yeah, but you and I are old
Roberts, so maybe that's
no, well, yeah. So, so Chad, you
don't have that feeling? Well, no.
The moment you said it, I thought I was,
I was constructing an image in my mind
of Neil Armstrong at a computer touching
the keyboard and there is an unbridgeable
gulf between his fingers and that
paper you're holding, they never
actually touched each other.
I mean if you think about it as
touch, then you're right. I guess he,
he's now dead. And I think if
just touching the paper, he would,
he would just be a little, I don't know,
a closer somehow.
It's a funny tension I
think because you know what?
Both science and at least
some philosophical and even
religious traditions tell
us is that the world is impermanent.
Nothing in it stays the same. Our, our,
we don't stay the same. Our
bodies don't stay the same.
The people that we love and the
things we love don't stay the same.
That's just the truth of the matter is
that there's this constant impermanence
and this constant flux and some
philosophers have argued over the years,
we should just embrace that we
would be freer if we didn't,
if we didn't try to hold
that flux for a moment.
I have to say my feeling about it is
part of what makes everything so precious
to us is exactly the fact that
we know it's going to disappear.
We know it's impermanent,
we know it won't last,
but what we love is this thing
now. We love our I. For me,
the most dramatic example of this is our
relationship to our children. So yeah,
we know they're going to go. We know
that in 20 years from now, if we,
they treat us with affectionate
contempt will be doing really well,
but that doesn't change the fact that
right now it's this child and not any
other child in the universe just
do this one. And I think that's,
there's something really deep and profound
about our human lives that the fact
that we can do both of those things.
We recognize the impermanence,
but that we feel the attachments that
that seems to me to give our life its its
very special texture.
Wow. That's exactly, I could
just put that whole thing.
You just hit it in the frame,
right. Just bow down. Yeah.
People don't bow too soon friend, because
the next segment, uh, is going to hurt.
It's going to hurt and it's a Tamar
wind is blowing. That's all I'll say.
[inaudible].